ellen or avocat c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir à la
norme merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on a vu à la façon de
répondre de donald trump à ces
destructions à ce vandalisme sur les
statues représentant des figures
historiques c'est vrai qu'en france même
si le pouvoir condamne
il n'y a pas la même violence dans les
propos ça ne vous étonne pas j'imagine
de la part de donald trump comme
réaction je ne pense pas que donald
trump et violent dans ses propos il est
surtout très politique il essaye de
galvaniser sa base électorale en disant
qu'il va renforcer les lois en déjà en
place les informations le média aux
états unis ont capté et les moments les
plus violents de ces manifestations mais
pas mais pas l'ensemble il s'agissait de
nom particulier dans beaucoup d'états
des communautés décide par vote de se
débarrasser de ses statuts alors
peut-être que vous ne trouvez pas
violente mais c'est vrai que le climat
était très tendu et très tendue aux
états unis notamment sur ces questions
de racisme de violences policières
est ce qu'un président n'est pas là
aussi pour apaiser les tensions apaisées
le climat tout à fait et ce que l'on
voit aux états unis c'est la
manifestation physique de tensions sous
jacentes
donc nous nous sommes en fait au point
de vue là sion d'ébullition et c'est
cela elle s'exprime sur les statuts sont
toutes sortes de personnes qui se
qui détruit ses statuts pas simplement
des personnes noires également des
personnes de couleur blanche
nous essayons de redéfinir notre
histoire et donc de se débarrasser de
ses monuments
et effectivement le président devrait
essayer de calmer la solution la
situation mais pour lui il s'agit de
faire entendre son programme de se
présenter comme président de la loi et
de l'ordre ont effectivement on n'oublie
pas c'est un président qui est en
campagne présidentielle et ça on imagine
que ça un poids dans le climat actuel
comment selon vous ce comportement de
donald trump cette stratégie peut-elle
influencer et peser dans la campagne
plutôt dans le bon sens pour lui ou l'un
verse
c'est une façon très traditionnelle de
faire campagne aux états unis il s'agit
de mettre de l'huile sur le feu du
offert de du rival un criminel
et dire que ce criminel vise l'histoire
les statuts de la base électorale en
2016 ont visé les immigrants qu'ils ans
qu'ils allaient venir voler les emplois
américains et la stratégie a fonctionné
à l'époque mais aujourd'hui la les
etats-unis se réveille
autour de ces questions de racisme et
beaucoup de jeunes personnes ne seraient
sans doute pas susceptibles d'entendre
ce message et d'oublier les problèmes
économiques les problèmes sanitaires les
problèmes de l'emploi et vous pourrez
comprendre que les statuts ne sont pas
si importantes en fait qu'elle
représente la mort et la haine pour
beaucoup de gens a toujours à propos de
donald trump à twitter masquer un
nouveau tweet du président pour aussi
comportement inapproprié le réseau
social va trop loin
selon vous c'est pas vraiment dans
l'esprit américain normalement de
censure mais twitter est une
plateformes privées et a le droit de
gérer des comptes la façon dont donald
trump s'exprime sur twitter peut parfois
sembler être un danger pour la
démocratie car on n'est pas sûr s'il
plaisante ou pas donc twitter à cacher
ce tweetup ce tweet cartonna trompe pas
d'autre façon de s'exprimer par exemple
fasse un micro enfin lui ça ne lui a pas
plu en tout cas il a contre attaqué en
publiant un décret qui met en cause une
loi fondamentale de l'internet américain
et cela ne correspond pas tout à fait à
l'action d'un président démocrate à la
mode occidentale
cela est plutôt autoritaire les
répercussions de cette action pourrait
avoir des effets à long terme sur les
médias mais je ne prends pas que je ne
crois pas que le président va gagner pas
remporté la partie à long terme parce
que cela pourrait se retourner contre
lui dans le cadre des élections et dans
ce cas tout ce qu'il fait en ce moment m
maurat avec la fin de sa présidence
aujourd'hui la campagne présidentielle
comment est-elle perçue aux états unis
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya énormément
de tensions vue de la france ça paraît
être
voilà un peu incroyable qu'à quatre mois
de la présidentielle il y ait autant de
tension comment ça peut basculer ça sera
ma dernière question pour les personnes
de couleur comme moi c'est une élection
c'est une question de vie ou de mort ne
font pas imaginer vivre à quatre années
de plus sous intel président c'est
également vrai par exemple pour les
immigrants pour la plupart des
démocrates c'est la démo
voici qui est en jeu droit par exemple
de vote
il ya beaucoup de questions qui seront
décidées avec cette élection
par exemple la question de qui peut
voter ce qu'est un sondage qui est un
pote
ces tables et comment utiliser
l'importance d'un président et savoir
que le président s'exprime et prend des
actions si dangereux encore et encore
cela est très inquiétant qui dès qu'on
veut garder la pureté de l'amérique est
très inquiétant qu'est ce que cela veut
dire donc c'est une élection très
importante pour les états unis également
court le monde car les états unis ont
toujours été à la pointe des mouvements
pour les droits de l'homme est
maintenant de nous retournons nous
replions ce n'est plus du tout la même
chose
merci elle à nos avocats d'avoir été
avec nous dans vu de l'extérieur ce soir